[Música]
[Aplausos]
si estuviese muerto en la calle nadie se
daría cuenta han cerrado las fuentes del
parque y no tengo donde beber agua ayer
por la noche quemaron todas mis
pertenencias y ahora tengo mucho miedo
el otro día intenté entrar en un
supermercado a comprar un paquete de
jamón de york y no me dejaron porque
dijeron que dormía en la calle no te
imaginas lo que es pasar un verano y el
invierno en la calle el sonido de las
cucarachas pasando cerca de tu cabeza
cuando te vas a dormir todas estas
frases me las han dicho personas en
situación de calle hola a todos soy
espero primero deciros que estoy
infinitamente agradecida y emocionada de
este ratito que tengo aquí para estar
con vosotros los segundos de más ustedes
presentaros a omar amarillo nos
conocimos hace tres años en mi plan del
jueves cuando estaba de ruta con la
asociación bocatas nos encontramos con
los bajos de azca él estaba en unas
escaleras y nos preguntábamos cómo nos
llamábamos y que hacíamos
a raíz de este primer encuentro se
empezó a forjar una relación o más se ha
convertido una persona muy importante en
mi vida de hecho está aquí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y a mí me gusta pago intento porque es
una persona que me ha enseñado
muchísimas cosas es sobre la vida no en
este ratito que tenemos social como
partícula ción y trayectoria vital en
los últimos años y como la gracia con
las personas sin hogar le ha ido
llegando por distintos caminos me tiene
el contacto con estas personas fue a
través del colegio y teníamos que hacer
las actividades y empecé como voluntaria
de las belgas san juan de dios allí pues
los martes también había hecho y vamos a
dar cenas y clases de informática y lo
primero que me sorprendió fue su sentido
del humor la capacidad de sonreír y de
hacer bromas cuando todo parecía oscuro
y odio cuando pierce y yo pensaba que
iba a encontrar todo boris todo triste y
allí no se veía pasamos un buen rato el
ayuda que se convirtió en mi segunda
casa y bueno yo creo que jamás en este
momento me imaginé que diez años después
iba a estar aquí hablando de esto y la
influencia que van a tener las personas
sin hogar en mi vida
cuando cumplí 18 años empecé a estudiar
la carrera ingeniería industrial y tengo
unos amigos que habían empezado como
voluntarios de la asociación bocatas y
me dijeron oye este 20 que todos están
en albergue han estado ya en este
comentario no tenemos que te puede
gustar y así pues como yo aterricé
aterricé en la asociación bocatas esta
asociación lo que sea dedicación es
acompañamiento a personas sin hogar en
situación de calle en mar y valentine
zaragoza y el bocata no es más una
excusa para que sea más fácil iniciar
una conversación para no llegar a manos
vacías y que sea raro simplemente para
emitir que hagáis de encuentros
semanales pues establece una relación
como cual cualquier persona que ves una
vez a la semana pues durante mucho
tiempo y así es como ellos han
convertido mis amigos a día de hoy tengo
grandes amigos que sufren esta realidad
y bien mucha gente dice james que traver
cuéntanos por qué una persona llega a
situación de calle pues hay una teoría
que lo explica fenomenal esta teoría de
los siete eventos traumáticos una
persona sin hogar sufre de 7 a 8 estos
traumáticos en un periodo de tres o
cuatro años cuando lo habitual es sufrir
tres o cuatro en sus traumáticos en toda
una vida
esto qué quiere decir historias de mucho
sufrimiento entre el periodo de tiempo
que pasa si el día de mañana te recortes
en tu empresa y disfrutes con tu mujer y
al mes fallece tu madre cómo sería si no
tienes una red de apoyo cuántas veces
habré pensado qué mala suerte qué buena
suerte porque en la calle no es una
realidad y lejana y ajena y a raíz de
estos quiero contar dos anécdotas que
han marcado mi vida uno de ellos yo hace
dos años ida los viernes con mi padre
aquí a comer a un bar del barrio de
cusco doblamos todos los viernes pues
conocíamos al personal y me acuerdo en
la cena de navidad evocadas que es un
momento especial porque estamos ahí
todos juntos cuando de repente ven una
mesa a uno de los camareros de esteban
ikeda nos miramos y al momento de los
reconocidos y pero javier que te ha
pasado no ya te contó como la pérdida de
empleo le habían vídeo para una
habitación y hace 50 años se le ha visto
durmiendo en la calle
y yo vamos a usar y en ella este no te
preocupes que yo voy a luchar de una
salida adelante ya mí para mi fuente
pero maría siento esta es mi realidad he
conocido chicos que tuvieron
articulación yo estuviera aquí en los en
los que si estás de maravilla y que
hasta ese momento su vida era más
parecida a la miel y son dos cosas que a
mí a pravia supuesto un punto de
inflección dije este es una privilegiada
y a día de hoy tu vida en caja pero así
podría no ser porque como cuando estás
en este mundillo empiezas a escuchar
cosas se hacen cosas y te das cuenta de
que oye de que nos puede pasar a
cualquiera y el problema aparte de que
esto sea de que es una suerte que es una
estación muy injusta para después pasar
a cualquiera es que es un colectivo que
está totalmente invisibilizado es que
vamos por la ciudad y paseando por las
calles nos hemos acostumbrado a que esté
parte de nuestras ciudades es parte de
lo que podemos denominar el mobiliario
urbano hay millones de estereotipos
sobre estas personas si buscamos los
medios de comunicación o las noticias en
internet que cuenta que vamos a ver
mendigos hay estudios que avalan que el
15% las personas sin hogar enfrentes
mendicidad yo voy en el metro a veces
idea personas que conozco y que se su
situación y nadie del metro se
imaginaría la situación que está pasando
esa persona entonces en se cuelan
etiquetas todas las personas sin hogar
viven
yo conozco un montón de personas sin
hogar que no beben y aparte la calle es
durísima para el codema es una
consecuencia de una causa y así empiezan
a poner etiquetas y etiquetas y
etiquetas y más etiquetas ante esta
realidad e injusta entonces es un
cuentito civilizado y que es muy
apaleado
yo cuando acabé la carrera en todo tipo
construcción estudiando catas y empecé a
trabajar en empresas vinculadas con el
gen y viendo que dos años eligieron a
gran multinacional y luego ya dije está
dándome en el plano más pequeñito estaba
en un proceso de búsqueda de búsqueda de
mi sitio ya de trabajar aquí y llegaba a
mi casa y me sentía totalmente vacía
sentía que mis días no me encontraba a
gusto yo lloraba valència mi madre mamá
es que yo no yo no vengo para esto yo es
que no canse abajo las calles y es
elegido estar en otro sitio como cuando
estás en una fiesta y veces que si todo
no va conmigo pues así me sentía yo que
eso que no era lo que yo quería no era
mi sitio y así en este proceso de
búsqueda pues acabé trabajar durante
casi un año en un centro de personas sin
hogar y han sido las experiencias que
más impacto ha tenido en mi vida ya la
de las más las más frustrantes porque al
estar todos los días con esas personas
pude sentir realmente cómo se
deterioraba y algo que llevaba la vida
en fuera de las entidades
era sentir cada día que estas personas
que llegaban con ganas ilusión de seguir
adelante con ganas de luchar con ganas
de etiquetas de caída pero quiero salir
como esas personas pasaban los días y se
deprimían tiraba la toalla empezaban a
consumir y la vía hacia atrás vía la
calle matta hay estudios que avalan las
personas sin hogar y una esperanza de
vida 30 años por debajo de la media
cuando yo trabajaba en el centro vino
pablo madrid es de barcelona porque
había oído en los medios que maría había
poco más oportunidades que estaba mejor
y a los meses de llegar su vida
apareciendo a la calle las hubiese
perdido más grande
cuando yo escribí este té justo acabamos
de enterrar a marius fuera primeras
personas y lugar para que establezca un
vínculo de verdad nos conocimos en los
bajos de azca era una persona principio
muy tímida yo acababa de aterrizar
enfocar está sociedad que es casi todo y
él se había roto un brazo e ir a
cantillo trabajar en construcción y se
haya visto en la calle y estuvo como una
marca y se puso muy enfermo muy mal y
todo el centro las veces recursos de
personas sin hogar y entonces durante
todos estos años mantuvimos nuestro
contacto nos veíamos os llamamos por
teléfono
y 1.50 22 años falleció y cuando
escribiste por supuesto seguían al
mortuorio del hospital la paz y no
teníamos respuesta de lo que iba a pasar
con el nueve días estuvo y tenemos que
hacer una presión brutal
con ello prepara este efecto lo primero
que hice fue mirar otros para recoger
ideas y un set que me encanta que si una
persona que te mapas y también que ha
dado hasta de profundo de estudios del
mundo interactuando con personas ha sido
varias ciertas fotografías y estuve en
madrid o en esas fotografías reconocía
te del día anterior había estado con él
y este vídeo fue delante a 2012 siete
años después la situación de pero sigue
siendo la misma pues toda esta
experiencia es ansiedad y un valor y una
frustración que no os podéis imaginar lo
sabe querido llorar gritar es entre una
ira inmensa una tristeza y quería salir
y empapelar la calle interiores de todo
porque me sentía he tenido angustia
vital o sea he llegado antes del centro
de viajes que qué va a pasar mañana con
estas personas que y la vida sino la
ciudad he tenido un dolor muy intenso
pero de todo ese dolor ha surgido una
energía brutal porque ese dolor y que
eso exista
y una energía muy profunda que brota de
lo más profundo de mis convicciones el
inconformismo en ataque además de
esforzarme en seguir adelante y este
dolor es el que hace que todos los días
me levante y a este para que para que
estudia hoy qué sentido quieres que
tenga tu vida entonces de este dolor
creo que ha salido algo muy fuerte y que
me proyecta y es esa energía tan intensa
y tengo la suerte y el privilegio de
comprender y compartirlo con un equipo
que es maravilloso bocatas que todos
tenemos esa energía y que es el motor
que nos mueve que nos hace soñar más
lejos y me gustaría estar más equitativa
a todos que estamos aquí abrimos los
ojos y el corazón porque todos da igual
porque esto yo creo que cada uno tiene
que buscar su vocación no yo estoy en
proceso de encontrar la mía pero da
igual donde estemos porque todos salimos
a la calle todos cada uno de nosotros
interactuamos con personas y todos
podemos marcar la diferencia yo estoy
convencido de que están nuestras manos a
hacer frente a los retos sociales que
nosotros enfrentamos hoy estoy segura
segura
saludo un gesto de buenos días una
simple mirada pude cambiar las
realidades porque nos lo cuentan esos
gestos cambian realidades las
limitaciones a abrir los ojos abrir el
corazón a nuestro entorno y y del que
vive otras realidades
por último empezó hablando mar y quiero
acabar hablando de más o menos una
persona que me hacía muchísimo como se
decía al principio hacía muchísimo sobre
la residencia de experiencia humana
actualmente está en un centro de
personas sin hogar nuestros centros
suelen estar alejados del núcleo urbano
nosotros lo que está cerca de la ciudad
y todos los días sale paseado otro
comercial a ver a las personas y
mientras me lo cuentas sonríe y éste ha
compartido su visión de la humanidad y
del mundo y del amor y con él ha
compartido mis cambios profesionales he
compartido que trabajaba en un centro
que pensaba mis cambios personales y
familia mi pareja y a través de sus ojos
he podido ver mi vida y la de los otros
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]